on va faire des ajustements au tir des
leçons j'ai parlé avec elle encore hier
soir j'étais il faut faire preuve
d'humilité dans cette démarche de
conversion des services en ligne faire
les ajustements mais on n'aura pas le
choix de se convertir au service en
ligne c'est une nécessité en 2023 mais
parallèlement à ça et ça c'était la
responsabilité de la SAAQ il fallait
anticiper et planifier le fait qu'elle
avoir plus de gens dans les bureaux qui
ont besoin de service
nouveau rebondissements dans le dossier
des délais à la SAC la ministre guilbo
que vous venez d'entendre avec ma
collègue Julie Drolet ce matin a quand
même annoncé trois mesures de sursis
pour résoudre le temps d'attente comme
la prolongation de la validité de permis
de conduire la ministre a bon espoir que
ces mesures viendront à bout des files
d'attente mais les causes de ce fiasco
de sont-elles pas tout d'abord numérique
le ministre de la cyber sécurité et du
numérique et mon invité ce soir incarne
d'avoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ça me fait plaisir madame
écoutez toute la journée les gens se
demandaient où étaient hericaire depuis
le début de la crise
écoutez compte tenu du fait que puis
vous l'avez entendu de la bouche de ma
collègue le madame Guilbaud compte tenu
que c'est un projet de la SAQ c'était
pour nous tout à fait normal les
légitimes classiques expliquent non
seulement ce qui se passait mais les
mesures que la SAC entendait prendre
pour corriger la situation maintenant la
situation ne se corrige pas et en plus
je vous dirais que le service
d'authentification de gouvernementale a
été amenée un peu dans les causes de ce
dérapage et je vais être très clair le
service d'authentification au
gouvernementale n'étant rien responsable
de ce qui se passe à la salle donc là
pour cette raison là oui je pense que je
devais faire cette mise au point
d'accord il y a quand même deux étapes
dès la semaine dernière les gens
dénonçaient le fait la légende interrogé
sur les files d'attente que vous exigiez
deux avis de cotisation je sais pas où
vous mettez le vôtre votre avis de
cotisation comme salarié mais bon dieu
il y a tellement de gens qui en ont pas
et que ça c'est un obstacle majeur en
quoi votre ministère responsable d'avoir
eu cette exigence c'est pour cette porte
d'entrée dans le système alors madame
monsieur vous me permettrez d'abord de
dire que nous on avait
retrouvé le juste milieu entre la
sécurité parce que aujourd'hui
l'entrevue que je vous donne et pas
parce que il y a eu des faux comptes ou
parce que des vols identité ou parce
qu'il y a eu des transactions
frauduleuses donc nous ma principale
progression comme ministre le sida
sécurité c'est de m'assurer que vous ne
vous faites pas voler votre identité ou
qu'on ne crée pas un faux compte à votre
nom ce n'est pas arrivé donc ça je pense
qu'en soit c'est une bonne nouvelle
maintenant vous avez raison pour
certains ça peut sembler compliqué mais
je vous dirais qu'à date je suis face à
deux types de personnes celles qui
disent c'est trop compliqué mais
généralement ces personnes là n'ont pas
fait la démarche et celles qui ont fait
la démarche et qui me disent mais
finalement c'est pas si pire que ça et
là-dessus je profite l'occasion que vous
me donnez pour dire on a mis en place
des services d'accompagnement donc vous
appelez service Québec on vous
accompagne dans la démarche si vous avez
besoin
du numéro d'avis de cotisation ou d'un
code secret on vous envoie un revenu
Québec une ligne dédiée exclusivement
pour ça et dans le cas de la vie de
cotisation on peut vous le fournir au
téléphone donc il y a pas de délai qui
qui est causé par cette situation-là
parce que si vous l'avez pas ce
programme l'agent de revenus Québec va
vous le donner au téléphone et il va
vous accompagner dans la démarche de
création du corps mais on sait ça
maintenant ça fait du plus dix jours que
la crise alors la question c'était ça au
numérique et je vais vous citer
vous-même si vous voulez dans un comité
de 2019 monsieur Ker lorsque vous avez
rendu public la stratégie de
transformation numérique j'en lis un
cours extrait pour le public la
transformation numérique de l'État
signifiera moins d'attente et
d'incertitudes moins de repasser au
téléphone moins de paperasse et de
démarches compliquées et plus besoin de
fournir à répétition les mêmes
informations tout cela en ligne c'est
tout le contraire que les gens vivent
les citoyens vivent depuis des semaines
sur le cas de la je vous rejoins et vous
dire que Madame Guilbaud le Premier
ministre et moi on est content de ce qui
se passe c'est c'est loin c'est loin de
la vérité on est absolument pas content
de ce qui se passe maintenant je pense
qu'il faut faire quand même la
distinction entre un projet qui connaît
des problèmes pour lesquels d'une part
il faut trouver des solutions corriger
la situation ramener la situation à la
normale le plus rapidement possible et
la possibilité que les services
numériques vont nous offrir à terme là
on est dans une situation vous avez
raison il faut trouver des solutions
c'est totalement inacceptable ce qui se
passe et nous ne l'acceptons pas donc on
va on va mettre en place les solutions
vous avez entendu la ministre des
Transports de la mobilité
il y a déjà des solutions de notre côté
on travaille aussi sur les problèmes
informatiques avec la sac pour régler ça
après ça lors des bilans arrivera et on
tirera les leçons qu'on a attiré de
cette situation là peut-être ça va
tenter à la vérification générale de les
regarder ce qui s'est passé par
l'autopsie de ce fiasco parce que
vendredi monsieur Legault déclarait j'ai
parlé à Monsieur car j'ai parlé à Madame
Guilbaud il y a des difficultés entre
autres entre autres à cause de
l'authentification donc le fameux
système d'authentification
gouvernementale va falloir le simplifier
et dès le 13 mars encore dans quelques
jours vous abandonnez cette exigence là
si je comprends bien
pour les gens qui vont se présenter pour
les gens qui vont se présenter au
comptoir
c'est ce que je vous disais
on est conscient que on peut améliorer
le service ceci étant dit moi je vous
donne quelques statistiques là à ce jour
on a créé
9495 code qui nécessitait le numéro la
vie de cotisation est revenu Québec a
reçu 383 téléphones de gens qui
demandaient à l'avoir alors moi je veux
bien l'autre la vie de cotisation c'est
un problème mais c'est pas ce que les
chiffres nous donnent et actuellement la
SAC nous dit on a
62866 individu qui ont été sur le site
de la salle et on a quatre au dessus de
80 9000 comptes qui ont été créés donc
j'ai
19000 comptes en fait mon chiffre c'est
81000 excusez pas j'ai 19000 30 du
service d'authenticité fondamental de
plus qui ont été créés que les gens qui
sont allés sur le site de Lasserre alors
moi je veux bien mais le service
d'authentification gouvernementale en
quoi est-il responsable des files
d'attente
de style Fortin dans les dans les
quotidiens le coop il disait que de lui
en tout cas que j'ai appris qu'il y
avait peut-être eu de la sous-traitance
à IBM IBM associée au chaos Phoenix à
Ottawa est-ce que vous avez sous-traité
la mise en marche de votre projet
extraordinaire de
projets informatiques est-ce que c'est
vrai que
je veux être très clair le ministère de
la Sécurité du numérique on s'est occupé
du service d'authentification au
gouvernementale le projet chaque clic
est un projet de la SAQ donc sur nous on
n'est pas impliqué dans ce projet-là le
développement l'élaboration du projet de
notre côté
recours à de la sous-traitance de votre
côté
il y a eu des sous-traitance parce que
il faut livrer le projet puis bon comme
tout le monde on est en recherche de
ressources on les avait pas toujours à
l'interne et je vous dirais que le gros
du travail et du développement céphane
interne maintenant je réitère l'entrevue
que je vous donne aujourd'hui n'est pas
une entrevue parce qu'il y a eu des
brides sécurité donc le système
d'authentification gouvernementale
fonctionne bien et les gens qui ont créé
leur compte l'expérience qu'ils en ont
c'est nous dire sinon c'est pas si
complexe que ça une fois qu'on a les
documents en main je vous conseille
c'est pas si complexe que ça et il faut
trouver cet équilibre en m'assurer que
la personne qui se crée un compte et
bien la personne qu'elle prépare donc
nous on a ce défi là aussi là parce que
on joue quand même avec les
renseignements
les décrets annoncés aujourd'hui par
Madame Guilbaud aurait pu être adopté
dès la semaine dernière ça commence
demain il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
qui sont encore pris avec le problème et
que dire des gens qui partent à
l'étranger pour travailler qui ont loué
une voiture qui s'en vont aux États-Unis
on a des voitures peuvent pas travailler
leur permis était juste c'est des
failles
vous avez pas à me convaincre que la
situation elle est extrêmement pénible
pour les Québécois vous avez
certainement pas à convaincre ma
collègue madame Guilbault c'est la
raison pour laquelle maintenant on
s'implique dans ce dossier là mes
équipes s'impliquent au niveau de la sac
mais voici une société d'État quand même
qui qui normalement assume ces projets
et assume c'est le développement et le
déploiement de ces projets maintenant ça
se passe pas très bien effectivement
excusez-moi
vous devez sauver la face
gouvernemental la stratégie numérique
puis là
en même temps
c'est pas le même processus pour une
société d'État que pour un ministère par
rapport à la réduction mais là je peux
pas tomber dans les considérations
actuellement on va trouver des solutions
lors des bilans va arriver et et après
ça on fera l'autopsie de ce projet-là
mais pour l'instant ce que les Québécois
veulent savoir c'est est-ce que le
gouvernement n'a qu'on est en recherche
de solutions la réponse à ça c'est oui
et les Québécois auront des réponses à
leurs questions qui sont tout à fait
légitimes merci beaucoup monsieur cas
c'est très apprécié que vous ayez brisé
le silence avec 24 60 ce soir merci
bonne soirée à vous pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI